وفي خضم هذه التطورات اعلن البيت الابيض
موافقه الرئيس جو بايدن على حزمه مساعدات
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 300 مليون دولار
اقلت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
كارينجمبير ان المساعدات الجديده تتضمن
مدافع
ومضادات للدروع واخره لمنظومه صواريخ
اداره بايدن ستعلن تقديم حزمه جديده من
المساعدات الامنيه لاوكرانيا لدعمها في
الاستمرار في الدفاع عن نفسها في ساحه
المعركه وحمايه شعبها ضد العدوان الروسي
الحزمه تتضمن المزيد من الذخيره لمنظومه
التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا بفعاليه كبيره
بالاضافه الى مدافع هارتزر ومضادات للدروع
وغيرها وتاتي هذه المساعدات بعد عمل مكثف
قامت به الحكومه الامريكيه على مدى الاشهر
الماضيه لتربيه طلبات اوكرانيا قبل الهجوم
المضاد المخطط له والتاكد من حصولها على
الاسلحه والمعدات التي تحتاجها